ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه اهلا بك معنا في محاوله لقراءه
مشاركه 12 دوله في هذا البيان ايضا قبلها
كان هناك خطوه قادها وزير الدفاع الامريكي
بتشكيل قوه بحريه لحمايه التجاره العالميه
في البحر الاحمر كيف تقرا توجه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لحشد الجهود الدوليه في
هذا
الاطار جزء منه عبد السلام متعلق بضمان
عدم اتساع نطاق الحرب الد في قطاع غزه
هناك حرص امريكي على ذلك من خلال القيام
بعمليه حشد وتعبئه لاكبر عدد من القوه
الدوليه كما تفضلت واشرت تم قبل حوالي
اسبوعين من الان الدعوه امريكيا الى انشاء
ما يسمى بائتلاف حراس الازدهار هذا يقوم
على تشكيل قوه مهام مشتركه تكون بشكل او
باخر بحمايه امن الملاحه البحريه خاصه
بنتكلم على منطقه حيو حيويه جدا للاقتصاد
العالمي بنتكلم على منطقه تقع بها ثلاث
مرات مائيه جيو استراتيجيه بنتكلم على
البحر الاحمر الخليج عدن الخليج العربي
نتكلم على ثلاثه من اهم الممرات الملاحيه
العالميه من ضمنها قناه السويس التي تربط
بين ثلاث قارات اسيا واوروبا وايضا
افريقيا وكذلك ايضا امريكا نتكلم على مضيق
بال المندب الذي يمر من خلاله على الاقل
30% من التجاره العالميه نتكلم على مضيق
هرموز وبالتالي نحن اذا بيئه جيو
استراتيجيه مهمه جدا في حاجه لوجود نوع من
الحمايه التحدي ال هو كيف يتم التوصل
لامرين الرئيسين الامر الاول هو وجود ما
يطلق عليه مديت او وجود نوع من التفويض من
مجلس الامن للقيام بهذه المهمه الامر
الثاني وجود نوع من الاجماع او الشراكه
الدوليه حتى الان يعتبر تحالف صحيح بدا
الد اليه عدد من الدول لكنه تحالف قد يبدو
بشكل او اخر تحالف فقط مدفوع بمصالح
امريكا التي هي بالاساس تقوم بالدفاع او
بحمايه ما يجري الان قطاع غزه من خلال دعم
اسرائيل وبالتالي نحن اذاء معال للعرض
وليس للمرض المرض الحقيقي هو موجود في
قطاع غزه نحن اذاء حرب همجيه مجاز مستمر
على مدار الساعه لقتل الاف المدنيين هناك
محاولات يستغل ذلك من قبل القوه الاقليميه
يك ال بالنسبه نعم هذه النقطه لماذا لا
يكون هذا هو الخيار الذي ترجحه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بينما كما تقول وستريت
جورنال هناك الجيش الامريكي بحسب مسؤولين
امريكيين يدرس خيارات لضرب جماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين لكنه ايضا اظهر اشكالا
بانها الاسلحه التي يملكونها هي اسلحه
متحركه لذلك ضرب النظام المسلح للحوثيين
صعب لماذا تبحث عن خيارات بينما الخيار
ابسط كما تقول هو يتعلق بما قالته جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين تخفيف المعاناه
الانسانيه لقطاع
غزه هذا جزء الرئيس عبد السلام مما اسميه
بالتناقض الامريكي السارق نحن وزا التناقض
الامريكي السارق فيما يتعلق بهذه الحرب ال
في قطاع غزه وهناك امثله كثيره على ذلك
فيما يتعلق بهذه النقطه تحديدا يعني بدلا
من القيام بتوجيه ضربات عسكريه للحوثيين
يجب ان تتوقف عن دعم اسرائيل طبعا توقف عن
دعمها عسكريا دبلوماسيا سياسيا ولكن نحن
نشهد امر متلق تماما يعني حل المشكله ليس
في البحر الاحمر حل المشكله في الدعم
الامريكي الصارخ او غير المحدود لاسرائيل
وبالتالي حتى لو افترضنا ان هناك سعي
امريكي دام اسدام القوه العسكريه ضد
الحوثيين بنتكلم على فتح جبهه اخرى للصراع
وهذا عكس ما تريده امريكا يعني امريكا
تريد طول الوقت وتحدث طول الوقت عن عدم
اتساع نفاق الحرب عندما تقوم بالتحشيد
وبالتعب وبار سال قوات الى هناك وبوضع خطط
لضرب الحوثيين بنتكلم عن توسيع نطاق الحرب
واي توسيع نطاق الحرب لن ياتي بخير على
امريكا بنتكلم على وجود مصالح امريكيه
استراتيجيه لاس فق في المنطقه العربيه من
خلال وجود قواعد عسكريه ممتده الامارات
والبحرين وقطر والعراق وسوريا بل ايضا
وجود قواعد عسكريه امريكيه في جنوب شرق
اسيا بنتكلم على الاف الجنود الامريكيين
هناك بنتكلم على ممر حيوي استراتيجي
للامداد و ودعم القوات العسكريه الموجوده
في اليابان وفي كوريا الجنوبيه وبالتالي
من مصلحه امريكا وجود استقرار في هذه
المنطقه من العالم واي حل مشكله المحه
البحريه عبد السلام يجب ان ياتي من خلال
اتفاق دولي او من خلال اجماع دولي او من
خلال يطلق عليه التعاون الجماعي نحن اذاء
ايضا منطق امريكي يقوم على استخدام القوه
بدون وجود اي منطق شرعي لها من خلال مجلس
الامن وع عن عن الاجماع الدولي عندما
نتحدث عن 12 دوله نحن نتحدث عن عدد قليل
وايضا في حتى في القوه العسكريه التي سعى
لتشكيلها وزير الدفاع الامريكي لم تتجاوز
اصابع اليدين والسؤال هنا عن لماذا لم
تتمكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
الحشد على مستوى الدول كما تقول بحيث يكون
هناك اجماع دولي على اي
خطوه هذا سؤال مهم جدا عبد السلام هذا
يعكس اولا عدم اقتناع الكثير من الدول
بهذه الحجه الامريكيه وهناك قناعه بان
المشكله ليست هناك في البحر الاحمر
المشكله الرئيسيه في وجود دعم امريكي غير
محدود لاسرائيل في وجود مجازر جماعيه في
قطاع غزه في وجود ماساء ماساء انسانيه
هناك في وجود رفض امريكا قاطع لوقف اطلاق
النار وبالتالي ليس هناك قناعه امريكيه
قناعه دوليه بذلك الامر الثاني مهم جدا ان
هناك دول ايضا اقليميه وعربيه تتخوف من
الدخول في هذا التحالف نتيجه ان قد ؤثر
على مصالحه بشكل سلبي يعني مثلا اذا كانت
المساله متعلقه بالحاله المصريه هناك خوف
من وجود تاثير تاثير لذلك على قناه السويس
السعوديه نفس الوضع هناك عمليه سلام بين
بين السعوديه وبالتالي هناك مخاوف من
انديم السعوديه لهذا التحالف الى تعط هذه
المساله وبالتالي هناك حسابات داخليه تعطل
وجود اتفاق دولي على هذه المساله شكرا
جزيلا لك من واشنطن الدكتور خليل الان
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه